[Musique]
il ya quelques années des praticiens du
chu de limoges et des chercheurs de la
faculté de médecine discuter et voulait
savoir s'il existait un dispositif
capable de les aider pendant les
chirurgie du cancer qu'ils ont trouvé
les a pas vraiment satisfait du coup ils
ont lancé un programme de recherche
ces recherches ont impliqué des médecins
des chercheurs en biologie et en chimie
des physiciens de différents instituts
et les différentes sociétés
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
de ce programme de recherche et de ces
travaux j'ai d'abord été séduit par
l'élégance de la solution qu'il propose
est et ensuite j'ai très vite vu
l'impact incroyable que pouvoir voir
cette technologie sur les patients alors
j'ai décidé de quitter mon emploi ne me
consacrer 100% à ce projet et j'ai été
rejoint par deux amis alexis et virgile
et aujourd'hui nous essayons de
transformer cette belle technologie en
un véritable outil alors comment faire
pour voir ce qui n'est pas visible
la plupart des choses qui nous entourent
et qu'on dit être invisibles sont
simplement trop petit pour qu'on puisse
le percevoir
et c'est le cas par exemple des maladies
et maladie on les voit pas directement
ce que l'on voit ce sont les symptômes
qui nous renseigne sur le fait que
quelque chose ne va pas cette maladie
deviennent des agents extérieurs comme
les virus ou encore les bactéries mais
pour d'autres maladies de notre corps
lui même et c'est le cas du cancer
tout au cours de notre vie à l'instant
même où je vous parle nous tous nous
avons nos cellules qui se régénère et
qui se renouvelle dans un cycle qu'on
pourrait apparenter à la naissance la
vie la mort tous à l'échelle cellulaire
par exemple le foie renouvelle
l'intégralité de ces cellules en 400
jours alors ceci c'est pas un alibi pour
vos prochaines soirées
on est bien d'accord et certaines autres
cellules son regret génère encore plus
rapidement c'est le cas pour l'intestin
l'intestin renouvelle ses cellules
entièrement tous les cinq joueurs et
durant toute notre vie tous ensemble on
va perdre à peu près l'équivalent de 20
kg de peaux mortes
ça vous repenserez quand vous verrez de
la poussière chez vous malheureusement
en cours de ce processus il peut arriver
que certaines cellules dégénère ça peut
avoir plusieurs causes
à la fois notre comportement des raisons
héréditaire ou des voix raisons
extérieures environnementale et ces
cellules vont se mettre à dégénérer par
exemple certaines d'entre elles peuvent
devenir immortel moi la première fois
que j'ai entendu que des cellules pour y
devenir immortel je pensais qu'on avait
tous vivre très longtemps
en fait non ce n'est juste à plat
complètement le processus et du coup
l'organe devient non fonctionnels donc à
la base d'une maladie aussi grave aussi
terrible que le cancer
il ya simplement des toutes petites
cellules et une cellule sa présence à
mesure environ 10 micromètres pour vous
dire ce à peu près 10 fois plus petit
que le diamètre d'un cheveu
c'est vraiment petit merci je regarde
c'est celui dont seulement à son tout
petit donc on les voit pas à l'oeil nu
mais en plus elles ont une faculté
incroyable est vraiment ambitieuse c'est
qu'elles se rendent invisibles pour
notre système immunitaire et du coup
notre organisme ne peut pas se défendre
contre ça il existe différentes méthodes
pour arriver à avoir des lésions
cancéreuses
par exemple il ya des marquages tumoraux
ont fait un prélèvement les marques on
arrive à détecter des lésions de
quelques dizaines de milliers de
cellules cancéreuses et aussi l'imagerie
on va injecter un traceur aux patients
utiliser un appareil comme un pet scan
ou un centime grave et on va pouvoir
voir des lésions de quelques millimètres
mais déjà le cancer représente des
dizaines de millions pour des centaines
de millions de cellules cancéreuses
enfin pour qu'une tumeur ce vraiment
visible à l'oeil nu et qu'elle fasse à
peu près 1 cm on parle de centaines de
millions de cellules voire de milliards
au cours de la vie du patient la plupart
de ces des cancers pourraient être
traitées pas voir chirurgicale c'est à
dire qu'un homme ou une femme va aller
sur cet organe dont il sait qu'il est
malade et va retirer les cellules
tumorales
mais à un moment donné malgré toute son
expertise et son expérience il va devoir
se poser cette question est-ce que je
continue de curé l'organe est ce que je
continue de retirer une petite partie de
cet organe si je continue je peux
retirer un tissu qui est sain qui est
fonctionnel et donc je veux entamer la
qualité de vie du mont patients on
comprend assez facilement sur des
conquis son niveau du cerveau par
exemple par contre si j'arrête
si je laisse comme ça là je prends le
risque qu'il reste des cellules
cancéreuses dans le patient est là le
cancer peut revenir récidiver c'est
justement pour voir cette frontière
invisible entre les cellules qui sont
saines et celles qui sont cancéreuses
que ce projet a été lancé
imaginez une cellule donc là évidemment
j'ai rétréci donc sur cette cellule
il ya plein de toutes petites molécules
et ses petites molécules toutes
différentes peuvent nous renseigner sur
le fonctionnement et le mécanisme
interne de la cellule
il suffit donc de trouver la molécule
qui nous dit que la cellule et
cancéreuses et c'est gagné
en biologie il existe les anticorps
peut-être déjà entendu parler et les
anti corses à faire plein de choses
notamment reconnaître et s'accrocher à
ses molécules en accrochant sur notre
anticorps influent eurofor influent
renforce une sorte de lanternes
biologique qui émet une lumière
lorsqu'on est clair on accroche donc ce
furent fort à notre anticorps et au
moment où notre anticorps accrocher la
molécule il va nous signaler que
celle-ci cancéreuses c'est déjà un très
grand pas ils sont allés encore plus
loin dans leurs recherches
et il se trouve que l'anticorps lors
qu'ils accrochent sa molécule
il passe des formes et il va en quelque
sorte comme plier ses bras et ça c'est
formidable parce qu'il ya un autre effet
physique qui s'appelle le fret roster
résonance energy transfer je faisais
tous perdu la chance donc ces superbes
effets il a assez simple à comprendre
mais d'incroyables on l'a 2 fluoro fort
de couleurs différentes
un rouge un verre chacun bri dans son
coin mais à un moment donné pour une
distance vraiment très précises ils vont
s'échanger leur énergie l'un va
transférer son énergie à l'autre ainsi
notre fluoro fort vert a commencé à
s'assombrir et le fluor fort rouge va
devenir beaucoup plus intense l'idée
qu'il y avait là derrière c'était de
prendre ces deux fléaux fort de les
accrocher à des endroits bien
spécifiques sur notre anticorps qui fait
que lorsque celui-ci par reconnaître une
cellule cancéreuse
en s'y accrochant il va modifier la
couleur ainsi à la place d'avoir une
lumière un peu verte et rouge
les chirurgiens verra uniquement une
lumière rouge lui signalant qu'il faut
continuer à faire son acte chirurgical
mais pour aller encore plus loin on a
pris ces petits anticorps on les a mis
au bout d'une petite fibre optique
il fait environ 2 mm de diamètre pour
aller directement au contact du tissu ce
patient et en injectant un faisceau
lumineux on arrive à savoir si les
tissus sont ou non cancéreux s'il faut
continuer ou pas à faire l'acte de
chirurgie pour donner les meilleures
chances compassion et c'est grâce à ce
projet qu'on peut améliorer la qualité
de vie du patient
tout ça en rendant détectable ce qui
était invisible
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]